Great. Welcome everybody.
This session is AACR, The
Next Generation of Extracellular Vesicles
and Particles: Biomarkers, Targets, and
Deliverables.
If I could have the first slide up.
Great. So I'm just giving a couple slides before we start.
As I mentioned, this is the educational
session on EVPs,
and as we all know, it's a very complex
field since mostly all cells can
secrete these EVPs.
But when you have cancer, you can imagine they're
secreting even more in number,
so we have to take that into consideration.
And which of the EVPs are being secreted when you have
cancer? Do you have larger ones, smaller ones?
And their composition is drastically changed.
All these factors, these EVPs can enter the
circulation
and educate multi organs,
and so these organs in turn can secrete
EVPs that go back to the circulation.
So when we're talking about diagnostics and prognostics,
these EVPs are not only tumor derived,
but represent abnormal exosomes that are being
produced by the immune system and distant organs
such as the liver.
So we have to understand the biology to begin this
whole process and the translation for us
to finally get to the point where we could use EVs as
deliverables.
So we all know about
mesenchymal and
all stem cells from your bone marrow as a native source, but
this population's expanding into platelet EVs,
and today I'm going to talk about T cell EVs.
Can we overpass the MHC
restriction and start treating patients
with T cell derived EVPs?
Or we
develop liposomal treatments which sometimes
lacks the direction. So maybe it's important
to take into consideration that we have to use a hybrid
that combines
the EVP directional source, such as
proteins,
with the liposomal network. So a lot of engineering's
taking place in the EVP world.
So we're fortunate to have a great speaker list with
Ghislaine and Dolores here today.
The first speaker is Ghislaine, who's going to give an overview of
EVPs. She's from University of Notre Dame,
and the title of her talk is "Extracellular Vesicles and
Particles, Their Biogenesis and Function."
Ghislaine?
Well, thank you, David, and it's great to be here
and
present this overview on extracellular vesicles.
The focus is going to be on vesicles.
I'll also be talking a little bit about
their role in the tumor microenvironment and mechanisms of
biogenesis, and also talk a little bit about the
work done in my lab in this regard.
So since this is an educational session, I thought I would
provide a little bit of a historical timeline on
this EV field, and it's been 80 years
since there was the discovery that
membranes shed from red blood cells were
able to shorten clotting time. And let me see, is this even
working? Yeah. And then between the '60s and the '90s, there
were several landmark studies that
basically made the case that
multivesicular late endosomes with internal
vesicles were able to fuse with the plasma membrane,
and those internal vesicles were then shed, and they were later coined
exosomes, as you can see in this electron micrograph here.
For some reason, I can't seem to be moving this pointer very well.
But anyway,
we'll try. There we go.
And then a big
bolster to EV research came from
three independent labs that
found that these shed vesicles were able to transfer
RNA to facilitate intercellular communication.
And I think that opened this whole
thought of these EVs playing a role in
intercellular communication and drew the therapeutic potential, and
that drew the interest of the entire
biomedical community.
Around that time, in the 2000s, there was also this renewed
recognition of vesicles that were
also shed
from the plasma membrane
by the budding and pinching of the plasma membrane.
And in this first study here,
the-Dolores DeVeliso and Mike Freeman
showed that in cell types that lacked the
actin nucleator,
diaphanous-related formin 3,
these metastatic prostate cancer cells produced these
large vesicles, which we now know
are recognized as large oncosomes.
And then in my own lab, we showed that
melanoma cells overexpressing a activated form of the
AF6 protein shed vesicles into the culture
media that were discernible to the eye,
and were enriched for the AF6 protein.
And, here are electron micrographs to show you these types of
vesicles that are being shed. So here you have both
by transmission scanning and whole mount EM.
You can see vesicles that are derived from the plasma membrane and those that are
MVB-derived. And as you can see, in the case of the plasma membrane-derived
vesicles, they are larger and more heterogeneous in size
relative to the exosomes that are released from
these multivesicular bodies that are 50 to 80
nanometers
in diameter and more uniform. So these vesicles
separate out by most size exclusion methods.
And the field has collectively referred to them as
extracellular vesicles. So fast-forward to the current day,
and we know that these extracellular vesicles are
ubiquitously secreted by almost all cell types.
They are evolutionarily conserved.
They have
overlapping and non-overlapping cargos.
They range in size all the way from these nanometer-type structures
to the micrometer-size vesicles, like microvesicles and
oncosomes.
And
extracellular particles are a newer subpopulation,
that lack membrane encapsulation.
I think
David Liden sort of pioneered this field with the discovery of
exomeres. And Bob Coffey's lab later then identified
supermeres. These have interesting proteins.
They are present in body fluids, and there is also then so a
potential
as biomarkers.
So the EV field, as in the
International Society for Extracellular Vesicles, has taken this very
pragmatic approach of classifying these vesicles based on
size. So anything that is smaller or greater
than 200 nanometers is referred to as the small EVs
or the large EVs respectively. So these small EVs
include the exosomes, like I just mentioned, these that are derived from
multivesicular bodies. There are several ways in which
cargos can be loaded into these vesicles.
Two well-studied ones are shown here, but additional
mechanisms also exist. So you have this ESCRT-mediated
sorting of ubiquitinated cargo into these intraluminal
vesicles. And then you also have this Alix and tenascin-R dependent
pathway, which also is dependent on changes to the lipid
membrane that allows the inclusion of cargos into these
vesicles. These small vesicles, these small ectosomes that bud
directly from the cell surface, also appear to require an ectosome
ESCRT type
machinery that's required for pinching from the cell surface.
And ESCRT is this endosomal sorting complex required for transport.
Now, the larger vesicles, on the other hand, are quite diverse.
There's quite a few of them, as you can see here.
There are microvesicles and oncosomes which form by the
budding and pinching of the plasma membrane.
There are these migrasomes that form on the retracting edge of the cell.
And there's this midbody remnants that are formed from a
post-cell division. And then the blebosome and
variations of it. This is the largest one
yet.
And they all appear to require actin-myosin-based
contractile forces for their release.
But they may also have perhaps distinct
biogenesis mechanisms, and that's something that is an
active area of investigation in the field.
So
these EVs, I
always think about them as functional units,
where they may bring about cargo exchange,
or signaling. They may contain molecules that serve as
decoys, like as one might see in the evasion of the immune
response. And they may also be a mechanism to get rid of
disposal of unwanted cellular material or waste.
And their collective action supports and sustains
microenvironments. And this is particularly true for the tumor
microenvironment, which as we know, functions as an ecosystem in which the
tumor will grow and reside. And these
extracellular vesicles have emerged as important
mediators of intercellular communication in the tumor microenvironment.
They may also be released into the bloodstream, into body fluids,
and have systemic effects and educate the
pre-metastatic niches so eloquently shown by David Liden's lab,
and like he just alluded to.
So these extracellular vesicles can bring about the
horizontal transfer of cargo, in the tumor microenvironment and bring
about processes as diverse as vascular growth and remodeling, and
CAF reprogramming, and ECM degradation and immune cell
evasion.
But there still is the-What we
still don't understand or appreciate is how these different
recipient cells can recognize
these different types of EVs, and how
cargos contained in these EVs might affect alterations to
recipient cell behavior. And so
reconstitution studies have shown that individual
subpopulations of these EV types can have different effects
on
each of these cellular responses.
So for example, in my own lab, in more recent work, we looked
at how these different EV subtypes might
facilitate the acquisition of pro-angiogenic
phenotypes. And what we
found was that these large EVs from metastatic breast
cancer cells or even melanoma cells induced very robust
induction of
endothelial tubes. In clear cancer renal cell models, cellular
models, both large EVs and small EVs induced very
robust tube formation, although the phenotypes,
the actual effects were quite different.
In one case, we saw an elaboration of tube length.
Another case, it was more of a sprouting phenotype.
So in all of these cases, pro-angiogenic EV
cargos varied with tumor type. And also the
pro-angiogenic cargos in each EV subtype
varied. So it's important to understand cargos that are present in
EVs, and also, it's equally important, I think, to
understand the biogenesis of how these cargos are delivered
to these different EV populations.
Because it would allow a strategy or an opportunity to
modulate the composition of the EV.
So,
while all of these are of interest, in my own lab, we've been interested in
how cargos are delivered to microvesicles.
And these microvesicles that are shed from most tumor cell
lines, their formation is usurped in tumor cell lines.
And so we refer to them as TMVs, and that's what you might see in
subsequent slides as in tumor microvesicle.
And this particular EV subtype is
characterized by the presence of the proteins Af6 and
Xena1 and the V SNARE VAMP3.
So
when we first began investigating these vesicles, it was
basically in the context of studying them in
the mechanisms of tumor cell invasion.
So at that time, we
isolated these vesicles, and we assessed them first for proteases.
So as you can see through this gelatin zymogram
of these microvesicles, you could see both high
and low molecular weight
vesicles. You could take these vesicles, put them on
fluorescent matrix, and they promoted degradation.
Here you see arbors of these vesicles that form
as cells invade matrix. And these are actively
migrating cells, and so quite different from the aptopodia that
has also been described in the literature.
And
so these are actually quite distinct.
This is a more rare phenotype, though.
What we really see is essentially budding and
pinching from the
vesicle surface
that allows these tumor cells to--
So these proteases get deposited to distal sites, and cells form
tracts in the media.
This migration invasion is MT1-MMP dependent.
Because if you block the protease, you sort of prevent the
formation of these tracts, and you get these cells just gyrating along the
matrix.
So the pinching of these
microvesicles is dependent on changes in membrane phospholipids
and also actin-myosin-based contractility.
Both the Af6 and Rho proteins have been thought to facilitate
this actin contractile force that's required
for this budding. It's also accompanied by changes in
membrane phospholipids. And so this mechanism of budding is
quite different from what you would see with the small vesicles that
pinch off from the cell surface and
utilize the ESCRT machinery.
Okay. The
proteome, it has a very diverse proteasome.
It also contains nucleic acids, both RNA and DNA, as is
common for most of these EV subtypes.
Which then led us to propose that perhaps these microvesicles that are
forming at the cell surface are convergence points for multiple vesicular
transport pathways.
And what we noted in particular was that many of the
proteins that regulated the formation of these vesicles
were
trafficked along this Af6 early endosomal recycling pathway.
Which led us to hypothesize that perhaps Af6 regulated recycling
was at least one particular mechanism by which cargos might be
directed to these sites. And that's what I'm going to focus on for the rest of this
presentation. So we find that these
vesicles
are shed from regions of high blebbing when tumor cells adopt
this very amoeboid phenotype. And here you can
actually see we were looking at how a protease might be delivered to those
sites, and you can see that the protease, MT1-MMP
localizes to these vesicles that are positive for the
endosomal v-SNARE VAMP3 that sort of directs
cargo to these sites. And there's very little overlap
between this protease and this particular v-SNARE when
cells are low blebbing and have this more spread or
mesenchymal-like phenotype. What we went on to
show was that this newly synthesized MMP could form
a tripartite complex with VAMP3 and CD9.
And then these vesicles
fuse. They join with the protease that is being
recycled along the early endocytic pathway.
And so these endosomes function as
reserves for the protease, and it's available
as needed depending upon when the tumor cell need to
shed these vesicles for degradation.Okay, so these TMVs also
contain RNA. There's a number of different RNA species that have
been identified. And what we found was when you
express, when you activate AF6, we saw an
increase in the pools of
microRNAs in these vesicles. And so basically, these
transcripts that were increased were of this pre-microRNA
size. And this
inclusion based on AF6 activation sort of suggests active
inclusion into these sites rather than just more mere coincidental
inclusion. And what the slide also shows you was
that this was corroborated with
RT-PCR of pre-microRNA targets, particularly those that have
a pro-tumorigenic role.
So it turned out that exportin 5, when we interrogated the public
databases, this exportin 5 or XPO5 was identified as a
binding partner for AF6. And in fact, this Prism
algorithm suggested a more favorable interaction with the
GTP form, so the active form of the protein.
And so we went on to show that this RNA
binding protein, this exportin 5, was present
in these microvesicles, both by immunofluorescence as well
as by Western blotting.
We showed through reciprocal and by both binding studies as well as
co-IPs, that there was a preferential interaction with the
GTP-bound form and in fact, very little binding with a
GDP-bound form of AF6. And we also were able to
isolate a complex of both
pre-microRNAs and the exportin 5 RNA binding protein and
AF6 from these TMVs
that were released. So
this is our working hypothesis for how this AF6
activation might be promoting microRNA traffic to
these sites where TMVs are being
formed. So first you have this export of pre-microRNA
exportin 5 RAN complex out of the nucleus, and
then there is this handoff or a delivery to an endosome to
the ANAF6 GTP-containing endosome.
We are not sure exactly of the mechanisms involved, but
we do know it does require CK2-mediated
phosphorylation of RAN GAP. There's also a recruitment of
a scaffold of the cytohesin 1,
GRP1, which functions as an exchange factor for AF as well, but in
this particular case, it functions more as a scaffold for recruitment of this
complex to the sites
of microvesicle formation.
And so,
this slide just shows you a couple of key things that
support the model that I just showed.
So this Prism algorithm actually
predicts an even more energetically favorable interaction between
AF6, GRP1, and exportin 5. We were able to
co-immunoprecipitate this complex from these
AmaBoy tumor cells. And loss of GRIP1 decreases the
amount of the
pre-microRNAs present in these microvesicles.
So since then, we've been profiling these
microRNAs from different tumor cell lines, and
what we find is that, while there is this global increase in
microRNAs, there are also certain microRNAs that are
enriched in
TMVs. So if you just put the whole thing together, we
think there may be this global RNA delivery, which is
endosome-mediated, but there may also be some sort of sorting
recognition mechanism that directs particular RNAs to these
sites and allows for enrichment of those select
RNAs over what's present in the cell.
So these RNAs that are trafficked to these microvesicles can
in fact be transferred to recipient cells.
So here we had these microvesicles that were incubated with
fibroblasts, and we were able to show that miR-21 from these
microvesicles were in fact transferred to these
cell lines. And
this transfer blocked was inhibitory to
a SMAD7 expression, and that this
phenotype was sort of recovered or reversed with knockdown of miR-21
or also by a knockdown of GRIP1, which was that scaffolding
protein that recruited these microRNAs to the
microvesicles.
Okay. So TMVs also contain DNA.
These are measurable quantities of DNA could be recovered from these
microvesicles. Biochemical and imaging studies in fact showed
that this double-stranded DNA was present inside
these vesicles, and these were benzonase-treated.
And
AF6 and activation led to an increase in cytosolic DNA.
So in the interest of time, I'm just going to briefly tell you that some of the
salient features of what we found is that these AF6 endosomes shuttle
cGAS cytosolic DNA complexes to TMVs.
And so we think that this is just a mechanism, one mechanisms by
which cells might expel double-stranded DNA into these
microvesicles. And cytosolic DNA is at least
one source of DNA that might be present in
these microvesicles. So,
in a nutshell, basically what I've shown you is that various molecular cargos can
be trafficked to these microvesicles via AF6 endosomes.
And this trafficking
is facilitated by the recruitment of carrier molecules or chaperones,
which themselves bind and facilitate the movement of either
microRNAs or DNAs or
proteins to the TMVs. So-Right before I
conclude, I want to bring up a couple of points that,
with respect, that remain
that are outstanding,
and germane to the
data that I've just discussed, but also to the field in general.
And the question is: Is there selectivity in cargo packaging?
So we know there are recruiting mechanisms, but when we sort cargo,
do we have vesicles that are
DNA rich as opposed to proteins rich?
And I think single vesicle characterization of cargos and single
vesicles would be important in this regard.
And then when it comes to these large EVs, the question is how divergent are they?
There's functional redundancy, there's cargo redundancy, and is it
possible that certain cellular contexts might favor
the
generation of a given large EV subtype?
They have common mechanisms for biogenesis, like all of them require
actin-myosin based contraction.
But if in fact they are unique and different, then are there sets of
regulators that are specific to a biogenesis pathway that would allow
us to distinguish between these EV subtypes?
Okay, so I'll stop there and thank
these people in my lab who have, in one way or the other, contributed to
all of the work that I just described today.
And
we thank our collaborators as well, and our
funding sources.
I'll take questions.
I can't see.
Thank you for the beautiful lecture and some very cool
science. I was
wondering, you showed how...
Pardon me, I'm not from the field, but it's so cool.
So
you showed how
some of the cargo that was the miRNA
ARF6 complex could actually reduce
expression of SMAD in the recipient cells.
I was wondering if there's anything that makes these
recipient cells more susceptible to receiving
that cargo, and what might that be?
And also,
are there mechanisms by which these recipient
cells,
they just take up this cargo so readily?
Because
from the little bit I know,
cells are not very
friendly to foreign
nucleic acids. Thank you.
Yeah. So
short answer to all of those questions that you asked was, we
don't know.
And we have been surface profiling a lot of these recipient cells
to see what sorts of proteins might be involved in those interactions.
And in fact, if that might provide some insight into what these
recognition
mechanisms might be. And,
what was your other question again? What was the second question?
Yeah. What are the mechanisms by which they're taken up?
So we've been investigating that as well.
We think that for vesicles as large as these,
macropinocytosis might be one way to take these vesicles up into cells.
But that too, I think, varies depending upon the recipient
cell.
So it could vary.
So an immune cell, for example, might take it up in a very
different way relative to say, a fibroblast might.
But we've been working through them, to figure out
what the mechanisms might be. And what makes it even more complicated is that
microvesicles generated from different tumor types
or tumor cell lines might
have different mechanisms of uptake with the same recipient cell.
So I don't know if there's sort of a consensus on any of that as yet.
I know that it's fairly complicated. But, yeah.
Thank you.
I see some hands up, but I can...
Can I go over here?
Over here.
Thank you so much for-
Oh
... for this talk.
Yeah. Over here.
Sorry.
Go ahead.
Okay.
So,
I just wonder...
That was wonderful, thank you. I learned a lot.
I was wondering whether, have you looked for these
similar ARF6 derived vesicles in
the microenvironmental cells and see whether those
will alter the cancer?
Yeah. Great question. That's something that we'd like to do.
We haven't done yet.
There are ARF6 positive cells that are
released by,
say, macrophages.
But we haven't really done anything in terms of assessing their function
yet. But that, yeah, one thing at a time.
Okay. Thank you for your talk. And
I was wondering whether these TNVs
impact on the immune escape that the tumor
put in place at the beginning of its development.
Can you repeat that question again?
If these TNVs-
Yes
... actually have
also an impact on the immune
escape that the tumor put in place at the
beginning of its development.
Yeah. So they do, if I understood your question correctly.
Yeah, they do seem to have an effect.
In ongoing work, we think that they're potentially tumor
suppressive,
with T cells. And,
even with macrophages, they might facilitate polarization
to a particular immunosuppressive phenotype. It's possible. Yeah.
Professor, thank you for the educational talk.
So my question is, when the EV is taken up by the cells,
so where the memory go? The memory
fused with the cells?
What was... Sorry.
The memory of the EV.
So it's-
Memory of the cells?
So yeah, when the cells take up the EV, so
the memory of the EV is fused with the
cells?
Yes.
Well, do they fuse? Do these vesicles fuse with the recipient cell?
Is that the question?
Yes.
Well, so
depends on the recipient cell. Sometimes we think that that might be the case.
In some cases, they're just taken up and they sort of
macropinocytosed in.
Oh, okay. So they-
We're still trying to figure that out
... can maintain their cell, like the memory inside of the cells?
I don't know that I'm
understanding your question very well.
Okay, no worry.
But maybe we can talk right after.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Are we done? Okay.
So it's my pleasure to introduce the second speaker,
Dolores Di Visio. And Dolores has two
labs. She just has one in Los Angeles, but
she's setting up a new one in Rome in
Sapienza University. So
she's a busy person right now. So we're happy that she's giving the next
talk on the biology to translation of
EVs.
Thanks, David,
for the nice introduction, and I want to thank the
organizers for giving me the opportunity to share with you today,
this educational presentation focused on cancer
extracellular vesicles. And, I'm very lucky that
Christine already gave a fabulous overview
of extracellular vesicles, and she
dived in the heterogeneity of these particles.
So I'm just going to add a few more concepts.
I like to use this slide because it allows me
to basically break down... Hold on.
Where is the...
I cannot find...
Why the mouse arrow is not
working?
I don't know. It was working before.
Anyway,
so this slide allows me to break down the complexity of this
heterogeneity in two major categories of vesicles.
There are the ones that originate by the endocytotic
machinery and derived by the fusion of the multivesicular
bodies with the plasma membrane, with the release of the so-called
exosomes. And, thanks to the work from
David Liden's group, we now know that even
exosomes, which are tiny vesicles, smaller than
150 nanometer, can be small and large.
We also know that as Christine already mentioned, there are even smaller
particles.
But on the other edge of the spectrum, there are vesicles that originate
by blebbing of the plasma membrane, as Christine
already alluded to, and they can be as small as the
exosomes, but also significantly larger.
And it's among these
larger vesicles that my lab has been focused most of the
attention. Here, there are a few examples, but we're
focusing on the cancer-specific large oncosomes.
We originally reported them by simply
identifying them by immunofluorescence in
aggressive prostate cancer cells stained with the lipid
dye.
And then we're using more
recently,
more sophisticated technology such as this scanning ion conduct on
microscopy that allows to visualize them in
3D. And as you can see, now we are switching
to
dedifferentiated liposarcoma cells, that
show this very large vesicle, some of which are larger than five
microns.
I'll give you an overview of what these large
oncosomes are.
They are generated by very aggressive
cancer cells. Not all cancer cells produce large
oncosomes,
in which there are cytoskeletal defects and nuclear shape
instability.
Compared to small EVs, because in all of our studies,
we have performed comparisons between these large oncosomes and
smaller EVs released by the same cancer cells.
They are the population of vesicles that is mostly enriched
in bioactive enzymes,
including kinases.
And when we compare their bioactivity also
in terms of
promoting androgenesis, as Christine was alluding to, but
also promoting tumor growth at the primary site, it seems that the large
oncosomes have a much more robust effect.
The other thing I want to mention upfront is that we've always
seen these large oncosomes as an opportunity for
translational relevance because
the presence of these large oncosomes
has always been associated with metastatic disease
in several studies. I'll show some unpublished
data, functional
dataRecently generated by
Tylon Silva, an outstanding postdoc in my team, and
now he's becoming an assistant professor at Cedars-Sinai.
He used this very aggressive model of
murine breast cancer that
spontaneously
basically metastasizes to the bone.
And after doing this orthotopic injection of the cancer cells,
he performed an EV education with small and large EVs
retroorbitally following a
strategy that David Liden has firstly
used a long time ago. And then after
excising the primary tumor, as it frequently happens in
patients with aggressive breast cancer,
we waited for the metastasis to arise, and what we noticed was
that the animals that received the large oncosome
injections
were the ones with
more metastatic foci.
And also in the group,
more mice in the group treated with large oncosomes
exhibited metastasis.
But how do they do this? We were not surprised
because as I mentioned, all bioactivity when we perform
comparative studies seem to be stronger for large oncosomes.
So we performed some
RNA-seq of bone marrow mesenchymal stem cells
exposed to large oncosome or exosomes, and we
realized that most of the
mRNAs that are stimulated by large oncosomes more than
exosomes,
they're part of a strong
inflammatory interferon response.
And we also started noticing that some of these chemokines
attract neutrophil migration. The neutrophil migration
was then...
I cannot move forward. Oh, here.
So the neutrophil migration was
validated in vitro by simple Transwell
assay on the left and by an
organ-on-a-chip, bone-on-a-chip microfluidic device.
And we also
noticed that these neutrophils not only migrate
toward the bone marrow MSCs treated with large oncosomes,
but they also have increased levels of
arginase 1 and IL-10, suggesting that they might have
a myeloid-derived suppressor phenotype.
The
mouse and the arrows are not working. I'm sorry about that.
Can somebody do something to help?
Okay. So,
then Tylon moved to another
animal experiment where he injected orthotopically these
4T1.2 cells, which are high producers of large oncosomes.
I need to advance.
Now I have the mouse, but I cannot advance.
Okay. So basically, in this model and
before metastasis occurred, what we
noticed when we isolated the bone marrow cells
from the mice
was a very strong transition to an
immune suppressive phenotype with the decrease of lymphocytes
and dendritic cells.
The monocytes and macrophages in terms of numbers were not
affected, but we noticed this increase of
myeloid-derived suppressor cells,
including those overexpressing PD-L1, suggesting that
maybe this is the way
by which large oncosomes induce metastasis.
And then we try to understand the mechanisms for that.
And we noticed that focusing on the transcripts that were
only upregulated by large oncosomes and not
exosomes, we noticed not only interferon gamma
signaling but also innate immune response to cytosolic
DNA and STING-mediated induction of host immune
response. So Tylon was able to demonstrate that if we
inhibit STING,
there was almost complete
blockage of the interferon NF-kappa B dual
reporter activation by large oncosomes.
And we had a similar result looking at
RSAD2 when the
DNA was abolished from the surface of large
oncosomes, as you can see also in the
super-resolution imaging below.
And finally, this was also confirmed by using
a STING-deficient mouse model,
in which the interferon-regulated genes
induced by large oncosomes, such as
IRF3 and 7, were not
increased.
So,
how do we take all of this biology and try
to identify biomarkers of cancer progression in the
circulation? When we all started considering
EVs as potential great opportunities for
liquid biopsy,
I think almost everybodyDidn't really realize how
complex is the blood and how many objects are there
beside the extracellular vesicles we're looking at.
And if we look at this electron microscopy image that I
kindly received by my colleague, Ring Newland.
We do, mom co-chairing the Blood EV Task
Force of the International Society for Extracellular Vesicles.
We can see how, of all of these particles, only the
five on the upper right quadrant are extracellular
vesicles. So there is a strong contamination by
other particles. Most of these might be
lipoproteins, all in this very small
size range. So we thought that maybe by focusing on
large oncosomes, we could resolve this problem,
because if we look at large vesicles only, and these
are tunable resistive pull sensing data in
four different patients with non-small cell lung cancer
in comparison with three healthy individuals.
We can see the very large population of EVs only in
the
patients.
But obviously it is also important to understand their
cargo. So in the past decade or so, my team has
been trying to characterize by using
multiomics approach all the
biomolecules present in these vesicles.
And I'm only showing these ones here.
So we demonstrated that if we compare
the content of RNA in
large oncosomes and small EVs, large oncosomes contain most of
the RNA, and we can also isolate these vesicles from
the plasma of patients with breast cancer and identify a
number of transcripts that have been shown to be upregulated
in patients with breast cancer at TCGA data.
We also
compared, for the first time, large and small EVs for their
content in DNA. We were able to do
all genome analysis of the large
vesicles only because most of the DNA is
contained in large vesicles. And on the top, there is an
unpublished result,
using all exome sequencing of large
oncosomes from the plasma of patients with
castration-resistant prostate cancer, showing that if we simply look
at copy number variation, we can identify
a tissue quality signal also in these vesicles.
This is also unpublished results using a
targeted panel
for a few samples of non-small cell lung
cancer patients, where we identified not only the EGFR
mutation but also other mutations that have been previously
identified either in lung cancer or in other tumors.
But most of our effort has been focused on proteomics.
And
I just want to highlight these among other studies, because here
we used
a novel approach, which is a focus on
palmitoylated proteins.
Trying to identify
more
large vesicles proteins because
counting on the fact that palmitoylation is a post-translational
modification that render the proteins hydrophobic and
probably
allows them to be bound to the membrane and shed in extracellular
vesicles. And we're currently moving on with
approaches that are more...
It doesn't move again. Sorry. That are more
suitable for patients, such as the
SWAT assay, and I'll show some data about that, and
more targeted mass spectrometry approach.
I'm trying to move on, but I can't.
Can somebody help, please?
Okay.
I'm trying to go to next slide.
I think I'm going to skip this because I'm
spending a lot of time on moving the slides
forward. So can we go to the next slide?
Are you trying to help me?
I don't know how.
Hi.
You see. Hello, how are you?
Good. How are you?
Good. I haven't seen you in a while.
No idea.
No, nothing. You're right.
I was right.
Connection here.
Sorry.
Does it work, Baba? No.
Okay. Keep talking.
Please tell
somebody. How are you?
Is it not? It's not doing anything.
Okay.
Sounds like...
There we go.
I guess this is kind of tricky.
But what about this? Oh, yeah. Okay, now it's going.
Okay, thank you. I'm so sorry about all of this, but
I'll try to go quickly after skipping this
slide.
Because I want to share some data from a recently published study
where we did a very big
effort toisolate vesicles
from different cancer cell lines, from different cancer
types, and plasma of patients with metastatic prostate
cancer. We used rigorous methods such as
ultracentrifuge differential centrifugation to separate the particles based on
size, and then gradient centrifugation to separate
them from any other material pulled down by
centrifugation with the vesicles.
And then we applied, in parallel, proteomics and
transcriptomics of the vesicles,
including the first
single large oncosomes RNA-seq
experiment. And by integrating all of this
data, we identified a subset of
proteins that were
present in all
of these conditions, and we classified
them as bona fide large oncosome markers.
We were also able to analyze these large oncosomes
from plasma of patients using data-independent acquisition
mass spectrometry. One of the
more interesting data was that the large oncosomes are enriched in
comparison to smaller vesicles with mitochondrial transcripts
and proteins, which was confirmed by the single large
oncosome RNA-seq experiment. And so this
convinced us more and more that large oncosomes are a
valuable particle for biomarker
identification.
Just some more data from this study showing that
we can separate
castration-sensitive from castration-resistant disease.
And also, because we had some longitudinal
sampling from these 20 patients, we could also see
a subset of proteins that was only present in patients
that exhibited progression. Only few of these
proteins were prostate specific, which is
now allowing us to
think to develop a large oncosome-based
multi-tumor profile in the circulation.
When we looked at the single...
This is not working again.
Single large oncosome data, in
collaboration with Francesca Demichelis, and her
post-doc, Yari Chani,
who had to develop
a new pipeline for the analysis of these large
oncosomes at the single vesicle level, but he used for
that the bulk RNA-seq data. And he was
able to confirm that most of the droplets in this chromium
10X assay were positive for large oncosome
markers. If I could go on. Oh, now I can.
And finally,
we were also able to demonstrate that the
majority of the droplets contained not
only large oncosome markers, but also
mitochondrial markers, confirming what we had already
found in the bulk analysis. So this work
allowed us to receive
a multi-PI awards from the NCI, where
we
are leveraging these large oncosomes to
phenotyping
their cargo in the circulation for ultimate evaluation of
patient status. And this is done in collaboration with
Shannon Stott, who recently moved from Mass General
Hospital to Boston University, and Francesca
Demichelis, and several
clinician collaborators who are giving us the opportunity to
work with over 1,000 samples. The reason
why we're ready to do this is because we have already identified the
large oncosome markers, but we have done that work with
very rigorous methods that are not applicable to the clinic.
So we're now moving forward, trying to create
a roadmap for
these
plasma large oncosomes
in a way that the methodology is also applicable to the
clinic. So I'll show some initial data,
where we are using these markers to develop a magnetic
beads capture, so it's affinity purification,
which seems to be very efficient
if we compare what is attached to the beads and what
is in the flow through,
to really pull down these large oncosomes.
And while we do this in my laboratory,
Shannon Stott is performing similar and
parallel experiments using microfluidic devices
that can also separate large and small EVs.
Once the EVs are separated, they can be also assayed by
simple digital droplet PCR, where we confirm the
enrichment for mitochondrial transcripts, or MIC
in this case, in large EVs in comparison to small
EVs. Uh-oh.
And then,
what happened?
Back.
Oh.Can
I try to advance?
Yeah.
I just want to advance from this when I get back there.
Sorry.
So did it just go by itself and do it? Is that what happened?
Yeah.
Okay.
So it might be a presentation.
Too much animation maybe.
No, it's okay.
Sorry about that.
It was here, right?
After this.
Yes.
Perfect.
And if for some reason, let me know, and I'll switch over, and you
can also drive this here, but you should be good with the mouse.
Not good with the mouse right now.
No, the mouse is not even working anymore.
Okay.
So I'll just use this. Okay.
Yeah.
Okay, thank you. Sorry again.
I hope I'm not taking too much of the time, but I'm trying to go
fast.
So
in work that has been going recently, Lauren
Newman has been able to set up the conditions to use
this super-resolution microscopy to look not only
at the presence of these
proteins on large vesicles but also quantifying them
at the single molecule level. And she's done
a truly amazing job at demonstrating the presence
of some of these proteins, not only in
non-permeabilized EVs but also in permeabilized EVs,
suggesting that these proteins, as we
expect, even if they are mitochondrial proteins, they are
identifiable on the surface.
The data can be quantitative.
And so she's been able to show that,
for example, VDAC1 and RP2 can be quantified
on the surface of these vesicles, not only when they are
isolated from cultured cancer cells but also
when we spike these vesicles in normal
plasma. And she's also starting doing experiments with
patient plasma, where we can see that these large
vesicles are very abundant.
And
these are the first initial data showing that we
can find a significantly higher number of these
proteins in large vesicles originating from
patients with metastatic prostate cancer.
And finally, to conclude, and in parallel with this
single EV analysis that we perform mostly
either by RNA-seq or by super-resolution microscopy, we are
also using flow cytometry.
We have at least two different strategies, one in collaboration with
Andres Zylstra, with whom we have
developed this EV fingerprinting
method. Which allows to characterize
different populations of extracellular vesicles based not only
on their biophysical parameters, but now
also on the markers we have identified.
And in parallel, we're working with John Nolan at
Cellarkus,
using a
completely different but orthogonal flow cytometry
strategy to quantify at the single molecule level
the
proteins on single large EVs. So in
conclusion,
it is one take home message that I
was trying to give, but I don't know if with all the
slides blockage, I don't know if it came across.
It is essential to enrich for EV subpopulations that
reflect more accurately
the tumor's genomic landscape. So this is very important.
We cannot just
pull everything out of plasma and expect to find this
specific phenotype.
I've shown you that large oncosomes contain more abundant cancer
cell-derived molecules. They're also suitable for
single large oncosome RNA-seq,
and they are a viable source of multi-analyte
circulating biomarkers.
What should really happen for EV-based liquid
biopsy approaches to reach the clinic and be
used
canonically in patients is to develop
biology-informed and highly rigorous approaches with
methodologies that are easy to be applicable to the
clinic and easily scalable. And with that,
I want to thank mostly the members of my
lab who performed the work, all of my collaborators,
most of whom I've already mentioned, the funding
agencies, the patients, and you all for your attention and
for your patience.
Question.
Thank you, Dolores. That was a very nice presentation.
Do you have a hypothesis on why you see this
mitochondrial transcript enrichment in the large oncosomes?
I don't have an hypothesis for why.
But I couldn't share
many data that we have on mitochondria becauseThis is
becoming highly interesting, not only in the EV
field but also for us.
So mitochondria have been shown to be released in
EVs for mechanisms that I think are completely unknown.
When they happen to be in large EVs,
as is the case for us,
we don't know if it's a passive
phenomenon. We don't know if it's because these
mitochondria are dysfunctional.
We don't know if it's because they are in excess in cancer
cells, and they are just
shed for this reason. And the reason why I'm saying
so is that we are also studying the function of these
mitochondria in EVs, and we have found, for
example, that while they consume oxygen,
they cannot produce ATP. So they might
be uncoupled mitochondrias that are defective
at some level.
Hi. Thank you for the educational lecture.
So I have a couple of questions.
First, regarding your 41 model, the
breast cancer.
So have you tried to block the release of
EVs, and then do these cells lose their
metastatic behavior?
Great question.
Great question because I couldn't show the data,
because I had also to focus on the diagnostic
applications. But we have a final experiment where
we use the same 41 II model,
in which we silence Septin 2, which seems to almost
completely abolish large oncosome production, and we
didn't see this
immune suppressive microenvironment.
And the Septin 2 is blocking only large
oncosome or all the vesicles released?
I think the data show only large oncosomes.
Okay. And then-
It's unpublished, though.
We're still working on that.
Yeah. And then just more in general,
related to the diagnostic potential.
So when you collect
the EVs from the plasma, from the blood of patients,
how can you actually be sure that it's produced by the tumor
cells and not by any other cells?
That's a fantastic question, and I cannot be sure, and nobody
can be sure. Even with the current methodologies,
even the most stringent are not going to
separate accurately the cancer-derived EVs from everything
else. But with our approach, we're trying to enrich them based
on the markers we identified using
the current strategy that allows us to separate them
at the best. But they're not necessarily only the
cancer ones. So in the final kit
that we might be developing, we're also thinking about doing some negative
selection, for example, for platelet-derived EVs.
So everything is still in the process of being fully developed.
Yeah. Thank you.
Great. Thank you, Dolores. So I'm going to end on
work unpublished, and it's going to involve T
cells, especially T cell DNA,
and we're introducing a new form of immune therapy.
We know CAR T cells, antibody therapy,
and we believe we could use EVs as an
acellular source
of treating cancer.
Okay. I'm going to review some of the work in the proteins,
but the main part of the lecture will be on DNA
from T cells. Here, this is a picture Dolores
showed, but we're going to be focusing on small EVPs
today, the exosomes and the ectomes.
So in the protein work, we showed a while back,
if we label these EVs after
ultracentrifugation, you can inject them
anywhere, and they go to specific sites.
So here's melanoma EVs. They like going to the bone marrow,
where they fuse with hematopoietic stem cells and a lot of
immune cells. And they go to certain organ sites.
Here, they're going to the lung and forming these
pre-metastatic sites, promoting metastases.
And you could use the Mast K sub clones.
They're triple negative breast cancer,
and these cells go to specific sites, such as the bone,
lung, and brain. You just grow these cells in culture.
You take the media, and you use ultracentrifugation, and you
label it with a lipophilic dye, and then you
inject them retro-orbitally. And 24 hours later,
they will go to the organ's future sites of
metastases. So in part,
the EVs answer Steven
Paget's mystery of why does cancer go to certain organ
sites. So if we use the EVs from the lung
tropic, 24 hours later, and then you look at the lung
by Odyssey Imaging,
those cells are taking up the EVs that are from the
lung tropic. If we image the brain, the EVs
from the brain tropic lines would be found
there.And
so we heard a little bit about diagnosis, but actually the
EVs have distinct protein markers for
prognosis. Can we predict who's going to have
metastases, which patient? And more so, can we
predict what organ they're going to metastasize to?
And here we find that the integrins always have a
role. They're specifically packaged in EVs.
They just don't represent what's in the parent
cell, so the integrin profile can be completely
different.
So if you have EVs with alpha V beta 5
integrin, they like to fuse with Kupffer cells in the
liver, like pancreatic cancer.
If you have EVs with alpha 6 beta 4 or alpha
6 beta 1 on their surface, they fuse with a variety
of cells in the lung and support lung mets.
Alpha V beta 3 is brain mets, and also we
found a unique hyaluronic acid protein CMIP
that promotes brain mets.
But little of the EV field is working on DNA,
and we originally thought, "Oh, this is bad." Oncogenes
transferred to stromal cells
in the EVs. And as we learned, and what you'll see is
that the more DNA is present, the
more there's an important role in the immune-to-immune
cell recognition and activation.
So complete surprise in our work.
So what we showed a while back that exosomal DNA
from tumors represents the whole genome,
and what we learned working, since our lab works on 75
different cancers and their metastatic outcome, we're very
different from most labs that focus on one type of
cancer. We found that the very highly aggressive
cancers, like pancreatic cancer, melanoma, have very low
exosomal DNA,
whereas cancers that don't metastasize, like the head and neck
cancers and some brain tumors, they have more
exosomal DNA presence. So we said, "That's interesting.
That's opposite to what we would have predicted."
So I'm going to focus on how the
EV DNA is really important for the
immune-to-immune cell
recognition, important in normal physiology,
as well as important in immune rejection of
tumors.
So here you could see DNA. It's present
mostly on the outside of the
EV. So if we use DNA as an enzyme, we
could actually get rid of more than 80%.
On the right there is a immunogold cluster of
DNA. You could see it's clustered to the exosome.
Sorry, as the mouse isn't working.
And so it's clustered to one side, and so
how it gets packaged is something we're trying to figure out in the lab.
We also use nanosite imaging here,
where we can image single vesicles.
So on the far right, you see double-stranded DNA
clustered to one side in purple. The
CD81 is representing the one EV.
And so if you use the DNA's treatment on the bottom
there, we can get rid of most of the DNA.
Also, we published that the histones are very unique in
extracellular vesicles. They're mainly cleaved,
which is a rare event for cells. You could see on the left.
And on the right, most of the histones that are packaged in the
EVs are methylated, suggesting they have
a role in epigenetic reprogramming.
So we wanted to find out what genes are
able to package EV DNA.
And so Han from South Korea,
he examined 21,000 genes, and it turns
out immune developmental genes are critical in EV
DNA packaging. You could see on the bottom in
red APAV1
and NCF1, which is neutrophil cytosolic
factor 1. They're all related to immune development
in some regards.
If we do the knockout of APAV1, we could eliminate the
DNA on the left,
and on the right, we could eliminate the histones that are
associated with the DNA.
And where we
give colon cancer to mice,
CT26 cells that are APAV1
negative, and we inject those into the spleen,
we could see that the primary tumors are not so different.
But on the bottom there,
far right, you see that the metastases is strikingly
increased in these APAV knockout tumors, which
now have less DNA.
And so the less DNA you have, the more
metastases you have.
So all this is pointing to the immune system.
So we then looked at all organs in the body.
I'm not showing you all of them, but the thymus gland has the
most EV DNA, spleen, followed by bone
marrow.
And working with Ben Stanger from UPenn, he gave us
pancreatic cancer cell linesThat he
isolated from KPC models associated
with low T cells that were highly metastatic, and on
the right, high T cells
associated
tumor cells that
rarely metastasize. And here he's just showing us
in his work, if you inject these two cell lines, he gets
metastases in the ones that have low T cell
association and less metastases than
those that have T cells.
We then examined the exosome DNA, and the one clones
that had high T cell exosomes had very high
DNA produced compared to the ones on the left.
Again, low EV-DNA, you don't
have the protection, and you get full-blown metastases.
So what does it mean if T cells release high
EV-DNA?
We first showed that T cells, especially
activated T cells that we culture with
anti-CD3, CD28, and
IL-2, we activate them, and
within three to seven days, we can
isolate EVs, and you could see the DNA goes up
significantly. This is in contrast to what
I just showed you, tumor cells, but also other
immune cells, DNA cells, like bone marrow-derived
monocytes and dendritic cells.
Here now, we can isolate activated T cell
EVs with high DNA.
What happens if we label these EVs and inject them
into naive mice? You could see in the far
left, these black regions is where the EVs are
uptaken,
but especially the lymph nodes. So non-activated
T cell EVs and activated EVs,
they both like going to the lymph nodes as compared to
3T3 fibroblast EVs that don't
go to lymph nodes.
And so you could see the lymph nodes are really taking up these T cell
EVs. And so in all of us right now,
when you have T cell EVs from your thymus gland,
they're going to your lymph nodes, and specifically on the far
right, are taken up by dendritic cells.
Not only that, we wanted to now look at the lymph nodes that are
taking up these T cell EVs.
And strikingly, the majority of the genes
are associated with antigen processing and
presentation.
So here you can see the top, but everything else below it
is also related to T cells and the immune
system. And if we treated
these activated T cell EV-DNA with
DNAs, get rid of the DNA, and then inject
them
24 hours later, and then we examine the lymph nodes, you could see
that none of the antigen presentation genes are
activated in the lymph nodes. So it's not like
proteins, microRNA, lipids,
it's truly the DNA that's making the difference.
Also, we could educate dendritic cells
from these EVs from activated T cells,
and they in themselves can activate future T
cells. So it's hard for me to point to, but the
second panel to your right, you see all the
generations of those dendritic
cells causing T cells to proliferate.
So the fluorescence is being passed on.
What about tumor-bearing mice? A
lot of these EVs that some are FDA
approved
and they claim like, "Oh, we can treat tumors,"
but in our hands, many of them don't go to the tumors.
So surprisingly, these activated T cell
EVs are going to the tumors. On the far left,
you see a red box. Those are KPC pancreatic
cancer tumors. So these EVs, 24
hours later, are being taken up there.
On the right panel, you see a mouse
that has a GBM-bearing tumor, a brain
tumor. They're taking up these EVs.
And what we find looking on the bottom there,
surprisingly, it's usually macrophages that are taking up
tumor EVs, and
they usually have the most important role in uptake, but
surprisingly, it was the tumor cells in that
primary tumor taking up the T cell EVs.
So what's driving, I said, activated
EVs as well as
non-activated ones? Both of those EVs are
getting to lymph nodes.
What's driving them there? Not surprising, it's another
integrin, and we find LFA-1, which is
alpha L beta 2 integrin.
And that integrin likes to bind to a number of things, which include
ICAM-1. So tumor cells,
especially the ones that we are working with,
pancreatic cancer, have very high
ICAM-1
expressionSo if we use an antibody
against ICAM-1 for a four-day treatment,
we can actually block the EVs from being taken up by
dendritic cells and tumor cells.
So what about the tumors? Can we actually use these
activated T cells to reprogram a cold tumor
like pancreatic cancer, which you never find T cells present,
triple negative breast cancer, GBM?
Can we make them hot tumors again and make
them immune responsive tumors?
So first of all, in the middle there,
we have ATEVs, those purple clusters.
We're using those that we isolate,
and we're treating Ben Stanger's tumor cells that are highly
metastatic. When we do that, now we can make the
tumor cells express antigen
presentation genes on the right in red.
And so if we implant these tumors, we're actually educated the tumor
cells that are metastatic every other day for four weeks.
We implant them,
and you could see that we can get lower tumor growth.
And if we take the DNAs away from the activated T cells
and educate these tumors, they now grow again.
And just to save time, you could see the beautiful lymph nodes
that you have a really nice T cell response
found
that could slow the growth of the tumor.
All these parameters, the good T cells and
activated DCs go up, while the
macrophages and myeloid-derived suppressor
cells are less.
And then we ask the question like someone asked a minute ago, when
we actually observe small EV uptake,
most of them are taken up by
the recipient cells and go to the perinuclear region
before we see them go to lysosomes, but
rarely do they go to the nucleus. Here, the
activated T cell EV DNA, not the
non-activated ones, can be found in
the nucleus. And on the bottom, you see those little
red dots. So the EVs are actually going to the
euchromatin region of the nucleus where transcription is
taking place.
And it's hard to see, but the activated ones have
granzyme B package compared to the
non-activated. So you actually,
after treatment with activated T cell
EVs, this is a fluorescence in the nucleus.
Those little white arrows show that the fluorescent is
actually being released into the
cytoplasm. So they actually disturb the nuclear
membrane, allowing the EV to get into the nucleus.
So I told you how the reprogramming at the
recipient cell, what about the genes actually
in the activated T cell EVs themselves?
Not surprising, the number one genes are all
antigen presentation genes.
And here, looking at all
the upregulated genes
associated with activated T cell
EV DNA compared to non-activated ones,
you could see there's quite a bit of
genes that are upregulated. One in
chromosome 17 is where we see the antigen presentation
genes. But all these other genes are related to the immune
system,
which I don't have time to discuss.
Also, which was remarkable, it's the donor
DNA that's driving the transcription in the
recipient cell. So in other words, if you take
mouse activated T cell EVs from, say,
mouse lymph nodes, and you're educating human
cells, it's the mouse
MHC genes, APP genes that are
upregulated, not the human ones.
And then we ask the question, is that activated EV DNA
getting inserted in the genome of the recipient cell?
No. Here, the lentiviral vector in
red is getting inserted,
but on the right here, the
ATEVs are not getting inserted in the
genome. So exactly what mechanism is
happening is we're still trying to figure it out,
how this transcription is regulated in the nucleus, a
unique cell biology event.
And importantly, can we use these for the future of
patients like those with pancreatic cancer?
So these are mice
that we inject KPC tumors on the top.
We let the tumors grow a week, and then we treat every
three days for five doses.
And on the far right,
you could see that if you just treat these
pancreatic cancers with anti-PD-1, the
tumors really don't go down that much in size.
Activated T cell EVs bring it down a little bit more,
but we found that reprogramming with activated T
cell EVs actually upregulates
PD-1.So the combination makes
the tumors not grow at all for quite a long time,
for 25, 30 days with these five treatments.
And you could see the tumors on the bottom are not
luminescing.
And we also bring in tertiary lymphoid structures on the
far bottom right with the combination therapies with only
five treatments. So now we're doing much longer treatments, and
mice are living with cancer.
Here's GBMs. We don't even have to use the
anti-PD-1 here. You just do five
treatments. The brain tumors don't grow.
The mice live another 30 days,
and we're replacing the tumors with all the
T cells and dendritic cells.
So in conclusion, we're showing that
activated T cells can upregulate DNA
and specifically package granzyme B, which
ruptures the nuclear membrane in the middle,
allowing the EVs to get into the nucleus.
And in response,
there's an activation of antigen presentation genes.
And so this is also important in a naturally occurring
gene therapy. So
Man Ying in the lab, who did all this beautiful work, is
now showing she can transfer certain genes into
genetic deficient cells and potentially using
this as therapy. But the reprogramming is
transient.
After seven days, the inflammation
starts going down with the antigen presentation.
So we're avoiding the autoimmune effects
seen with other therapies.
So I just wanted to thank my lab, who did all this work, and my
wonderful collaborators. Many of them are here at
this meeting. So thank you, and I'd be glad to answer any
questions. I think we have a few minutes. Thank you.
Yes.
It's Patrick Houma from the Cancer Center. Very nice talk.
Is the STING pathway involved in the DNA activating
the dendritic cells, the antigen processing presentation?
Yes. So that's a good question. So when you take the
DNA away,
and they get into the cytoplasm,
as long as they stay in the cytoplasm, like the
non-activated ones, you could get STING
activation. These are getting into the nucleus so
quickly,
and although we see a minor contribution of the
STING activation pathway, it's very minor,
unexpectedly. It's the non-activated ones
that still are doing something in the cytoplasm that activate
STING.
Thanks. And do you think these T cell EVs are also contributing
to autoimmunity?
Well, like I said, we only give five treatments, and then the
inflammation of antigen presentation starts
dwindling down if we isolate tumor cells and dendritic
cells seven days later.
So I think they have a minor role, if
no role in autoimmunity, actually.
But naturally, in a lupus patient, for example, there might be-
Yes. That's a good question. We're actually
studying the DNA and granzyme B in lupus
patients with Virginia Pasquale right now, and we just don't know the
answer to that. But great question.
Yes, over here.
Hi, Dr. Lennon. Very beautiful work.
My question is, do you know how these exosome
DNA
are cleaved and transferred outside the nucleus and
packaged into the exosome? Do you know detailed molecular
mechanism?
Yes.
You're asking about how they get packaged in the first place?
Yes. See, we're trying to figure that all out.
We're actually doing a genetic screen on the T
cells themselves, not just relying on the tumor
inflammation, where we got immune developmental genes.
So we can have a better sense of what specific
genes on the T cell side are responsible for
EV DNA packaging. So we have a lot of work to figure it
out,
and everyone just assumes they go through nuclear
pores to the EVs, but we don't know
yet.
Thank you.
Over here, is there a question?
Hi. What do you know about the structure of the DNAs
in the EVs? Is it naked?
Oh, good question.
Is it nucleosome associated? Is it packaged in chromatin? What does it look like?
How big?
As I mentioned before, they can represent up to
10 KB size of DNA collectively,
but we're now examining
exactly what this DNA structure. Is it linear or
circular, extrachromosomal DNA?
So we're working a little bit with Paul Michell's group
here, trying to figure the structure.
And also, do you know anything about whether the toll-like receptors are involved
in recognizing it when it's transferred into other cells?
So far, they didn't seem to have a big role for us at the
EV level.
Over here.
Other than antigen presentation, can-
Wait, can you speak up a bit?
Other than antigen presentation, can you
upregulate also major histocompatibility antigen in
tumor that are low?
I'm sorry, I couldn't understand your question.
So you show that you can increase antigen presentation,
but there are tumor that are major histocompatibility antigen
loss or low.
Yeah. So the tumor-- Yes, I see what you mean.
What about in this case? So it's useless just having one and not the other.
So can you modulate both?
Yes. So the tumors will
upregulate MHC quite a
bit and produce EVs now, like I showed you in the
beginning, the tumors that don't metastasize, and they'll
upregulate DNA as well. And so it's like a
full-blown cycle. We can really influence the tumor
cell itself, and the tumor EVs can further
help
exactly continue this cycle.
Okay, over here.
I think we have time only for one more question. So here.
Okay, mine is not question. Thank you very much for a great presentation.
I just would like to know how we can reach this study.
You have similar paper or this one been published or not?
How we can reach?
Yes, so this paper will be online in two weeks
in "Cancer Cell."
Thank you very much.
And that, since it was so fast, one last question.
Thank you so much. Wonderful, beautiful work.
And I have technical question. How much time EVs were treated with
DNase?
How much time what?
Yes, the treatment of EVs with DNase, enzymatic
treatment to get rid of DNA, surface DNA.
How long do we treat with DNase to get rid of the DNA?
Exactly.
Yes. So that's just, actually, you just add it and you can get
rid of it right away in hours. Three hours later, it's off on the
surface.
Yes, and does it affect EVs?
Excuse me?
And another question, if that time affect
EV's structure?
No, it doesn't. That's a good question.
We actually have that nanoSCI
imager, and so we could show that
proteins are not affected by the DNase treatment
on the surface, like integrins, they're all present there,
including the histones.
Yes. Thank you. And second question about distribution of this
DNA surface versus lumen.
Do we know how much is
in a specific compartment?
Yes, say that again. You're asking about distribution and what?
I
ask about percentage of DNA outside
and inside EVs.
Yeah, the distribution I said was 80% on the
outside and 20% on the inside.
Okay. And the last question, the time of co-incubation EVs
with
recipient cells, and after what time we can
observe perinuclear localization?
Yeah, we do 24 hours. If we do a long
reprogramming, it's three to four weeks.
Okay. Thank you so much.
Thank you. So I want to thank the other two speakers,
Dolores and Ghislain. I think they were outstanding today, and
I hope you enjoyed the world of EVs.
We started
just a few of us, a handful, 20 years
ago. And actually, we have the leader in the field,
Laurence Zibregel. She's now focusing on EV.
She's here today. She started it with Clotilde Thery,
that jump-started the whole field, and now she's a world expert on
microbiota. But it's really exciting to see
how many people. We have our international meeting next
week with 1,000 people coming, so
it's just wonderful to see, and I hope many of you will think about
doing EV research and translation.
Thank you so much.